like a mom-and-pop shop
independent yes oh that'd be better
okay
i'm just gonna see how many times i can
say shiplap before they you guys count
okay okay
and then i want to read some mail from
yours yeah good idea i had stuff to talk
about that caroline and i went over okay
i'll talk about that too
but first
hello
yeah ship up do you have shiplap
skip
no i'm sorry i don't know but you know
what it is right shiplap yes you do the
shiplap goes on the walls and sometimes
you don't have to paint in between
the ship up so if i'm not getting
shiplapped what do you do you have
something like shiplap
no nothing like that but
the shiplap
for the wall
we don't carry any shiplap no but you
have
shiplap like um where i can uh cut the
wood into shiplap from uh non-shiplap uh
wood
shiplap ask them if they have shiplap
i'm on the phone with them now lou
shiplop
lou wanted me to ask i told him i
already asked you what did you want to
do ship flap did you have a ship
is someone on first who's on first we
want some [ __ ] ship left [ __ ]
is this
lou
and lou and howie
lou and howie are you eating something
i am what are you eating
french toast
[ __ ]
[ __ ] delicious do you have a shiplap
[Laughter]
yeah come on down i got your shiplap
well you do have shiplap because a
minute ago you said you didn't have
shiplap now you have shiplap i'm on my
way want to talk to tyler yeah let's
talk to ty let's talk to tyler maybe he
has hey does does tyler have shiplap
i don't have any ship left i'm sorry
that's why i'm calling you guy
i love it hey thanks for that i was
looking for
go ahead i was looking for shiplap too
do you have shiplap
i love it this is great
what's great the french toast or the
shiplap
the the we don't have any shiplap but
don't worry let me write that down you
don't have what
no shiplap ship laptop
i saw that you could get other panels
for shiplap and it doesn't have to be
wooden panels yeah they don't have to be
wooden panels to create shiplap what do
you have to create up from there i don't
have anything to create a chip up i got
a bunch of tools what's the best color
for shiplap yes yes i like purple
no no no no purple shiplap you have
shiplap tools
yeah of course
what is the best shiplap tool
um any tool actually is good for shiplap
it just depends on what kind of
shipboard you got right what kind of
ship
lap i would recommend you know
uh the shiplap extreme plus
20 volt i was looking for budget ship
lap that does not sound very budget to
me no definitely not budget no high-end
called the wrong place if you're looking
for budget ship lap that's for certain
okay are you guys on technical we're
high-end ship lap store sir so really
keep that in mind
we're we're on parthenia one block east
of rocita boulevard and if i took the
101 how would i get there did i get on
the phone you would get off that
repeater yeah get off that receipt you
can take the 101 to resida how about the
10. go up go north on receiver right now
and the 10. can i take the five and the
10.
what are you gonna go oh you're gonna
pick up do you deliver shiplap or will
does he have to pick it up
no we don't have any delivery i'm sorry
right there do you deliver it buy a ship
yes we could ship that over oh but of
course it's not left what's the extreme
lap shiplap uh maybe the guy that'll
deliver it from the ship his name could
be lap i don't know
this is lap from shiplap incorporated
this is in fact
there's too many questions going on one
at a time please can you dance and do us
a ship laptop do the ship lap poem
oh no we don't do any ship laughs lap
dances i'm sorry
dances
you know what you get if you have a
shiplap dance you end up with morning
wood
[Laughter]
was a closure that's it i'm actually
i'm actually can i use this on my
podcast
[ __ ] yeah you can what podcast is it uh
i'm doing the howie mandel podcast today
oh nice do it i should he does it with
his daughter jacqueline and his friend
lou
and the guy here dave from texas
tyler from dave texas
sorry nice
yeah
yeah do it use it okay what's your name
are you the owner
yeah my name is randy and i'm the owner
okay we can use it thank you randy randy
were you close with a song about shiplap
i don't have any shiplap songs but i
appreciate it anyway no oh you
appreciate shiplap songs
of course
my friend
ship laughs
yeah i would have thought that it had a
much faster pace than going [ __ ]
okay my daughter you gotta come up with
something a little bit better than that
that's too slow no
you know what now you're screwing with
us well and we don't have time for that
this is very serious we are uh
very all right
stick with the ship lap buddy we can
handle the now
many many years ago called chirp
and it goes like this
chirp chirp
chirp
chirp chirp
chirp
[Music]